[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell join this
hour by the amazing Jade warshaw and
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in if you've got a question about
money you heard something on social
media you're wondering if it's true your
broke brother-in-law gave you some real
estate advice let us be the third party
to talk you off the ledge and avoid some
terrible decisions and if you've made
some terrible decisions and you're
self-aware call into the show we want to
help you climb out of that hole we are
specialists in that because we've done a
lot of dumb things ourselves and we're
happy to help triple eight eight two
five five two two five well it's been a
fun week on the show I kicked it off
with my friend Ken Coleman and we talked
about the value of the US dollar and why
you should be more worried about your
own personal Behavior than a total
economic collapse and then Jade you and
Dr John Maloney had some spicy calls oh
my gosh a woman called in where her
mother-in-law had stolen three hundred
thousand dollars out of the the
inherited IRA would have fallen out of
my chair I I did almost gracious and you
guys talked about the perfect storm of
Stupid Money habits brewing in America
yeah that's right all the credit cards
and he locks and taking out all this
debt how it's affecting Americans at a
very real very catastrophic level and
then you you wrapped it up with uh some
crazy stuff that you know we've all done
to get out of debt you specifically did
some extra crazy stuff oh yeah I told
John the story about uh searching for a
keyboard that ended up being worth only
twenty dollars and I also told him
George the story of the infamous nude
Crews I just heard the story today and
it just tickled me so be sure to go back
listen to this week's podcast episodes
and her favorite podcasting platform
YouTube or a Ramsay Network app and
check those out yes I can see the studio
audience they really want to know more
about that nude Cruise a lot of intrigue
you gotta watch the episode that's
that's what we call tease in the biz all
right let's kick it off with Josh in New
York City Josh how you doing this hour
very good how are you we're doing well
how can we help
I'm calling because I have 8 500 in
credit card debt
um
self-employed but past couple months the
money's been pretty much
you know unemployed levels it's been
really bad so I know I need to go to
full or part-time job to pay off this
debt but I've been working in film for a
year and I want to figure out
you know how to keep my career going and
combine these two and pay off the debt
quick
Okay cool so you're working in film and
the work has been pretty dry lately
it's it's been it's been hit and miss
what would you say on average is your
monthly income from this
dude that's an Uber also but really it
maybe like
you know 400
400 a month from film
yeah how long has it been like that Uber
on the side
um
like two three months okay and before
that how much were you making
um
probably in total maybe like 800
so how have you been surviving because
you live in New York City so what have
you been doing to cover the bills I live
with my family okay so you have low
expenses but you've been going into
credit card debt to cover what
um the debt was actually because I had a
six months like alcohol problem and I
just
racked up a bunch of debts for an idiot
yeah what are you doing to um help out
with that alcohol problem are you seeing
somebody are you in counseling
yeah I've been three weeks clean and I
have a counselor so awesome that's great
news yeah so let's talk about the money
side you've got 8 500 in credit card
debt you have low expenses because you
live with family do you have any other
type of debt
no just this okay what are you doing in
film what exact role
um I act but also I do different jobs on
set lighting assisting
second directing okay I imagine New York
City there's all kinds of side hustle
opportunities outside of the film
industry completely outside of even Uber
yeah
and so I would start to look at what
skills you have and even if there are no
skills everyone can go get a retail job
work in Hospitality serving coffee shops
you name it
that's right George makes a good point
Josh just you know when you're when
you're in the Arts sometimes the Laura
is well this is my job this is my craft
and you you kind of uh
don't want to put any time into anything
else but at the end of the day you do
have to make money You Gotta Eat You
Gotta make those ends meet so that
you're not having to go into credit
cards and things like that but I kind of
want to raise another issue here because
it sounds like this has been going on
for far too long just this kind of
Barely getting by barely making it and
of course you kind of had that bout with
alcoholism and I really want to
challenge you to get to the bottom of
what that is because something is is
eating away at you to the point that
you're not doing all that you could be
to to go after this and in in my opinion
it seems like it's linked in some way so
I want to really encourage you to keep
getting to the bottom of what's causing
you to kind of put forth minimal effort
in this what's kind of causing you to
revert to some some negative behaviors
there because I don't think that
us just telling you hey here's what to
do with your money is necessarily going
to be your solution today although we're
happy to do that
am I touching on something
yeah I mean one thing the reason that
probably a big reason about why my
income with film is like this now is
because during those six months when I
was like that I turned down a lot of
work that I shouldn't have so I kind of
derailed my career for a bit and do you
have an agent that you're working with
that helps you book these gigs
uh I do it just myself at casting
agencies and people you know friends and
anything on the internet okay now I'm
guessing you have a lot of friends in
this industry
I have a couple yeah I would start
conversations with them you want to find
something that's flexible to where if a
gig came up you could go take that gig
and do this work that you love that pays
really well but in the meantime I'm
getting a full-time kind of retail job
that has a more flexible schedule
because we can't live off 400 bucks a
month
yeah and so we needed we need a bigger
shovel right now so that one day you can
get out of your parents house is that
the ultimate goal
you know I planned on doing that this
year but I got terribly derailed last
year you know life history how old are
you
26. okay well the good news is you've
got lots of time on your side and I want
you to dig deep and find that why that's
what's going to keep you going when
you're like why I'm working 60 hours a
week I'm not doing the thing I want to
do find that deep y if that's I want to
get out of debt so I have the freedom to
do acting and pursue film that's a great
why if it's because I don't want to live
with Mom and Dad anymore while I'm when
I'm 34 that's also a great why and we're
going to give you a tool to help with
that called Financial Peace University
as well as every dollar premium that's
going to help with budgeting it's going
to help you get this new information
it's going to help motivate you to
actually change your life and keep it
that way yeah and write those goals down
write them down write them down on paper
put it somewhere where you see it every
day whether it's those sticky notes on
the mirror share it with somebody so
that there's some accountability in
place because that's really what's going
to motivate you to to get to the next
level with this thing absolutely hang on
the line Austin's gonna pick up we will
hook you up with Financial Peace
University and every dollar we're
cheering you on man addiction is one of
the most difficult things a person can
go through through and the fact that
you're on the path you're working to to
get a point in life where you're doing
the work you love and getting paid to do
it I'm just so proud of you man stay the
course this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined this hour by Jade
warshan we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right Jade about a thousand
people have sent this news over to me
and so I feel like we have to talk about
it before the week is over and it's
about Apple and you know I'm a big apple
Fanboy I used to work at the Apple Store
I look like the just every Apple
employee you've ever seen and I'm a big
fan of Apple but I'm not a fan of their
latest program Apple pay later oh no
it's here folks and it's more dangerous
than I could even explain Jade you know
why because no one has to sign up for it
it's already built into your iPhone I
hate this I hate it already and I don't
even fully fully know what it is yet but
I kind of do so yeah we decided to make
this a surprise for Jade because I'm a
giant nerd so I'm just looking at this
stuff all day run down the facts for me
George so on Tuesday Apple launched
Apple pay later and it allows users to
split purchases into four interest-free
payments paid over six weeks with no
additional fee hate it so you buy
something for 100 bucks Apple pay while
you're checking out with apple Bay says
hey why pay 100 bucks now you can pay 25
now and pay the other 75 over the course
of six weeks so you're paying 25 a week
for a hundred dollar purchase ish it's
over six weeks okay okay so there's no
interest or fees you're not paying any
more for the product so people out there
are going well George Jade what's wrong
with this what's wrong with there's so
many things wrong with it well keep your
own keep going so here's what happens uh
prior to making a purchase Apple pay
later users can apply for a loan so I'm
glad they call out that it is a loan
people why God it's not alone between
fifty and a thousand dollars is what you
can use this for oh my God you can use
it for in-app purchases online retailers
that accept Apple pay which is pretty
much everyone these days and so Apple
conducts a soft credit check they review
your credit score and they promise that
this process won't impact your score and
if you're approved you'll see all of
these payments in your Apple wallet and
so it's built into Apple wallet will
show exactly what you owe and that's it
you're applying for a loan right at
checkout and so as you spend during the
week you have all these tiny little
micro loans that you owe money on
now you're wondering what's the catch
right and because it's a zero percent
interest rate there's no fees four
payments over six weeks but here's the
catch Jade Apple makes money from the
transaction fees yes right the swipe
fees they're The Interchange fees so
when you make a purchase Apple gets a
cut of that and so Apple stays out of
The Fray here you know who you're gonna
hate the bank the bank because what
happens when you have 17 payments and
you can't budget for that and so all of
a sudden you overdraft
because you didn't realize how much you
actually spent because in your brain you
spent 25 percent of that amount and now
you overdraft and that incurs a 35 fee
forty dollar fee every single time it
overdrafts I am just beside myself I
need for people to understand if a
hundred dollar look I don't want you
putting anything on payments but if a
hundred dollar purchase or a 50 purchase
you're like you know what let me just
spread this out over six weeks you can't
afford it
Jay the the VP of Apple pay her name's
Jennifer she said in the press release
she said well we wanted we built this
because we care about the Financial
Health none of our users that's what we
we had the Financial Health of our users
in mind and we want them to have
flexibility Jade that's all it is here's
the thing why spend all that money now
they have other bills to pay okay then
let's let the let's let the viewer weigh
this or The Listener I should say way
this are we going to listen to Jennifer
who we've already understood is getting
a kickback every time you go into debt
or are you going to listen to Just Me
and good old George here on the radio
who are making no money off of this we
just care about your well-being we
understand the damage that debt does to
people like you're you're eroding your
future for a 25 payment if you didn't
have the hundred dollars today or the
extra 25 today chances are you're not
going to have it next week you're not
going to have it the week after that and
then I'm just thinking about just the
generality of this like if you're
spreading money and payment it's over
weeks most people aren't getting money
every week most people are on a you know
they get paid twice a month or once a
month that sort of thing like this is
this is a bad bad idea this is a bad bad
bad idea George here's a here's a
financial concept oh don't buy things
you can't afford what's so old-timey and
so let me make this very clear for all
of you watching out there Apple doesn't
give a rip about your Financial Health
they exist to make money they are
launching this to make money and steal
market share from all these buy now pay
later companies that are out there and
and more than that that's it you can
tell by the the type of debt this is who
it's aimed at all right the folks who've
got a little bit of money
they're not doing by now pay later
they're just buy now pay now it's by now
pay now this is aimed at lower income
people people who are living paycheck to
paycheck people who are already
struggling and they're making a bad
situation worse and I can't stand that
George I cannot stand companies who
their entire uh income structure is
based off of you or me failing you or me
defaulting you or me not being able to
make ends meet I hate companies that
earn money that way and I for one refuse
to participate in it and I hope that you
do too man this is this is terrible
stuff this is this is like the payday
lender this is like a digital payday
lender yeah but it looks better because
there's no interest in fees they go well
Jade it's a great option but here's
here's what Clara found and they brag
about this to retailers these buy now
pay later companies they're scum clarna
on their website brag to retailers that
consumers will spend up to 45 percent
more if you have buy now pay later on
your website
wow and here's the thing they're telling
you what they're doing to you and all of
you out there are going sucks to be them
and yet on Twitter if you look up any of
these companies like oh dang Clan are
going to kill me this month with all
these payments oh well YOLO I hate it
this is the mentality of a generation
but here's the thing and here's where
the internet gets us because
most I'm going to be careful how I say
this most of us who use buy now pay
later we would not be willing to walk
into a payday loan store because you
feel the stigma you see it you know it's
always in that side of town or it's
always you know you don't want to walk
into there and you don't want to you
know tell your friend hey I'll be right
back I'm just going to the payday loan
store you don't want to tell them that
but because it's digitized it looks
fancier it looks sleek it's like hey
it's just buy now pay later but I
guarantee you we wouldn't do that if it
was put in a different format do you
know what I'm saying oh yeah I mean it
lives in our pocket it lives in our
pocket there's no shame it's just us and
here's what it is it's frictionless
spending and the more can conveniently
make it the stupider we get and the more
broke we become it's that simple yeah
talk about that George the frictionless
spinning because we know the studies
around that the difference between how
your brain actually functions when you
spend money on with cash versus plastic
versus really nothing just the magic of
the interwebs right you go to the
grocery store with 200 cash from your
envelope system because you're working
this plan it physically pains you to
hand over 200 in cash and you lose that
money yeah those centers in your brain
light up because it knows you better
cash now you don't have it the cashier
has it when you use a card any card
debit card credit card you don't feel
any pain you swipe and then you leave
with that card and you leave with your
groceries and so your brain says that
didn't hurt at all and now with our
phones I don't even have to pull out a
card oh man I just hold my phone over it
and then the phone says hey why spend
100 bucks I'll give you 75 off just
spend 25 today we'll worry about the
other payments later and what does that
do it causes you to be broke
because you can't mentally or physically
budget for all of these different
payments coming out and in your mind
you're saying well I'm giving myself
flexibility no what you're giving
yourself is acid reflux down the road
when that thing overdraws on your
account and now you're getting dinged
for 40 bucks
a Time and that keeps happening the
overdraft is going to be so millions of
dollars from overdraft fees oh yeah and
the Apple's genius in this because they
go well they're not going to be mad at
us we didn't do anything wrong it's on
the banks it's on the users I want to
know okay and meanwhile their apple is
the one conducting the soft credit check
yes right they want to make sure you're
in good Financial standing if they're
going to loan you a thousand bucks oh my
gosh it's just so bad that in a second
somebody can say you're in good
Financial standing just in a second
think about think about this think about
how long it would take you for those of
you who you know don't really budget
don't really you're you're getting on
track with your money think how much
time it takes you to sit down you look
at your expenses you're listing
everything out and it takes time to see
really what the state of your finances
are absolutely but Apple knows Apple
knows in in three hot minutes whether or
not you can be loaned money they're
telling you hey we know the state of
your finances we think you can afford
this we're gonna issue you this line of
credit come on does that really does
that even I really want to love you
Apple but you're making it difficult and
I'm doing my best Ted lasso impression
with my track jacket today and it's it
really I was going to watch the new
episode tonight and I don't want to now
well they're just a taste in my mouth
for jumping on that bandwagon of easy
money taking advantage of folks taking
advantage of the least of these
financials there's a wild idea for Apple
maybe make a better product if you want
more money maybe innovate a little
God Steve Jobs is rolling around in his
grave right now going really guys this
is what we've come to being in the
payday lender of America with Apple pay
later just say no your wallet your
budget your financial future will thank
you for item is the Ramsay show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Jade
warshaw this is the Ramsey Show open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we are headed to
Boston Massachusetts and Chelsea is on
the line Chelsea welcome to the show
hi thanks for
sure how can we help
you cannot afford my husband and I
bought a house in August and we are
having some buyers remorse and we're now
wondering if we should sell our house
whoa okay walk us through what happened
well um a few months after so we got
married in August and I said butterhouse
um and we we instantly had the buyer's
remorse because that was about the time
we got into Dave and baby steps and
um the house is definitely not what he
recommends
um but then I also lost my job so that
was about a hundred thousand dollars
um
pay cuts
and we've been working with a financial
advisor and we've cut out everything and
we're on baby step two but we we're
barely making ends meet and last night
um we had to spend about ten thousand
dollars to save our puppy's life that we
didn't plan on
I'm so sorry you guys have been through
it
we have it's been a rough um our I mean
our mortgage is Now 52 percent of our
total income um take home pay let's take
home pay yeah okay well and
um yeah so we were debating selling our
house
um we think we have a maybe a little bit
of equity
um and just renting and starting fresh
but we didn't know if that was a
terrible idea so are you working again
what's your current income
um I took a job that I
and about 40
000 um
based so it has the potential to make a
lot more than what I was making but
it'll probably be about
six months to a year before I really
start seeing those commission checks
okay and what's your husband's income
um he we we own a gym so he brings home
it's kind of it's different since it's
self-employed but like probably around a
hundred thousand okay so let's say 150
000 household income before taxes
okay what other debt do you have
25 000
we now have the ten thousand dollars
that we had to put on a credit card for
the dog and then we have
um one other a couple other credit cards
totals about six thousand dollars okay
now I'm assuming with this mortgage
payment you guys don't have a lot of
wiggle room at the end of each month to
even throw at the debt nope we've cut
out everything that we can excuse me um
please cut out completely everything
that we can so it's we're actually we
use every dollar and when we do our
budget we're about negative 100 every
month and we've just kind of lucked out
and that's with you guys really dialing
in the budget
yeah but just between the debt payments
the mortgage and paying just straight up
bills I mean you're not doing any
frivolous spending it sounds like you've
played that game yeah we have no
frivolous spending we've started using
cash to buy our groceries
um do you guys have any savings in the
bank or anything you could sell
um
other than our we're upside down in the
car that we do have which is why we
didn't sell it yet
um we had the thousand dollar savings
that is now gone as as of last night and
no no other savings what's your home
worth like would you pay for it and
what's it worth
um we paid 769 000 and two it's a new
development neighborhood and two other
houses in the neighborhood recently um
one recently sold and one is currently
on the market and once they're those
sold for about 8.50 to 915.
okay so and you said you have a little
bit of equity
we are well so we we only put down I I
don't mean I think we put down five
percent
um because it was my first home purchase
and we did a 30-year mortgage um
so are we owe 750 and we we're thinking
we can maybe sell it for 8.50 okay so
you might net a little bit of cash that
would help you start attacking this debt
but it's not like a silver bullet
no because now we got to pay rent and we
still have probably 75 grand worth of
debt to tackle
yes have you priced out some of the
rents in your area compared with what
you're paying now
we did we did that right before we
called you um we could probably rent
something for about three thousand um so
that would save us about 2200 a month so
your mortgage payment is 5200 a month on
a 30 year
yes man I gotta tell you Chelsea I I
hate telling folks to get out of their
house George that's a big move I
actually rarely tell people to sell the
house but this is one of those
situations where I wouldn't be able to
breathe if I were you she can't breathe
you can't we can't y'all can't y'all you
can't breathe I mean like it's you've
cut down your budget to nothing it's a
skeleton you're both working and I know
there's probably some months where the
gym is doing better than others but you
don't know that and you're on commission
and and here's the thing when you're on
in debt and you're working it changes
the way you work you've just got that
that crazed mentality so it's probably
not doing anything to help you in your
job right now
um do you know what I'm saying am I
right yeah you know you don't want to be
a desperate salesman you don't want to
be a desperate salesman
um
I I hate to say it but something tells
me the moment that you break free of
this you're gonna exhale and you're
gonna be like Ugh thank God we can
breathe again
I would at least start the process reach
out to a realtor we have some great
Ramsey trusted Real Estate Pros you can
connect with at ramseysolutions.com and
to start the process see what the
Market's actually doing how much you
could get for the house and while you're
doing that I'm going to start working my
tail off to see if we can get some
traction and maybe have an ultimatum and
say hey if things aren't in a much
better place three or six months from
now where we can see the light at the
end of the tunnel we got to sell this
house this is the monkey on our back
that's killing us okay and and here's
what here's here's another reason beyond
the money you guys are newlyweds you're
starting out life you don't want to
start out life
there's enough stuff that you're
learning being newly married right you
don't want this pile of debt just
making matters worse or making matters
stressful like that first year of
marriage is Tough Enough can I get it
amen George amen is it just me okay
I'm just saying I think that
I just think in the Long Haul it's going
to serve you serve you better and you'll
have a home that's a blessing and not a
burden and most of the time people have
done this they look back and go that was
the right move rarely do they go oh my
gosh if we wouldn't have sold her how it
could have been this much no one's
thinking about appreciation all you're
trying to do is survive in this state
and so it really does it will speed up
this process of helping you guys become
debt free much faster and then when you
go back to buy a house the right way
it's going to be a blessing in your life
instead of a curse that's right when you
save up 10 to 20 with no payments in the
world and probably more because it's you
know freaking Boston and homes that are
crazy expensive yeah and so crazy it may
be another five years before you guys
are homeowners and that's okay that's
all right but don't believe the lies
that everyone needs to jump into Home
Ownership it sounds like you had some
pressures in your life we're like hey
you're married now you got to get it
home what are you doing wasting money on
rent was that the narrative
um it was more like we had it was like I
said it was right before we got into
Dave and we had Justified it as we were
paying separately before we were living
together
um about 8 000 in rent he has his three
thousand minus five thousand so this was
saving money
five thousand dollars for rent wow yeah
Boston
um
I do have a question because I've heard
that if I guess someone told me once
that if you sell your house before two
years you get some kind of fees for that
is that you will have capital gains yes
okay 15 right George
but for most it depends on your incomes
I'm guessing with your incomes it would
probably be
um it may it may count kind of just
extra income at that point if it's
because it's been under a year
yeah if your income is it looks like if
your income is if your taxable income is
more than between 41 and 459 000 okay 15
percent
so I would also look into the tax
implications you it may just be a net
wash and that's okay we're not selling
this house to make a giant profit we're
doing it to get out from under this
giant payment and like you said it's
going to free up 2200 a month plus
that's borrowing nothing else goes wrong
with the house I mean what happens if
the HVAC goes out tomorrow right and
well luckily it's a it's a new
construction so we you have a one-year
warranty yeah well why we're talk while
we're talking about fees or things that
might come up I gotta say this right
quick I gotta talk about this dog right
quick because when it comes to these vet
vet bills and and you just got through
something where you spent ten thousand
dollars
if you need to put a cap on that because
if if Rover is still not doing so well
and something pops up later you've got
to have a cap on what you're going to
spend on this you can't continue to go
into debt for a pet
I'm sorry but you can't do it
sometimes it feels like dog ownership is
more expensive than homo I know I know I
just lost a lot of friends on that she's
just telling it like it is well we are
rooting for you Chelsea thanks for the
call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
all right let's clear something up if
you listen to the show for 10 seconds
you'll find out we are not a fan of debt
in fact we hate it and some people they
don't get that they think you need debt
you need credit cards to build your
credit because you need a good credit
score to buy a house right wrong that's
a myth the truth is if you're living a
debt-free lifestyle eventually you won't
have any credit score and you got to
find a good lender like our friends at
Churchill Mortgage who can do something
called manual underwriting with a no
score loan that's where they personally
review your financial history to a
preview for a mortgage very old-timey
and this way you can avoid the credit
score game altogether I have done this
Jade warshaw has done this and so we can
tell you from personal experience you
don't get a vote your opinion doesn't
count here it's something that people
can do people do it all the time so this
might sound crazy but the best plan for
your future is to avoid debt save a big
down payment and get a real estate agent
who will help you find a house you can
actually afford and we recommend agents
who are Ramsay trusted meaning their top
performers with years of experience
helping people like you do home buying
the right way
none of this is impossible you can buy a
house without a credit score you can
find a house that will be a blessing not
a financial burden and you can find a
real estate agent who will help you do
all of that by going to
ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramseysolutions.com agent
all right let's head to the phones Lexi
joins us up next in Phoenix Lexi welcome
to the Ramsey show how you doing
good how are you guys doing great how
can we help
um I'm just looking for an opinion on
how much we should be spending on a
minivan oh fun
we always kind of go as cheap as
possible with our cars and we had a
salvage title one for a while and it fit
the desk a few days ago so uh we're
trying to decide if it's a good time to
spend like 30 000 on one with low
mileage so we'll just drive until that
dies as long as possible or if we should
stick to closer to ten thousand and buy
one with higher mileage because we're
trying we're hoping to buy a house
within the next year
do you have do you have any money set
aside for something like this aside from
your yeah we do um we sold our house
like our townhouse recently and we're
just renting for a year so we have about
250 set aside for a down payment on top
of our six-month emergency savings
awesome and no debt I'm assuming yeah no
debt none at all
free screen yeah congrats so you have
250 and you would dip into that to pay
for the car
yeah and so we're just deciding how much
of that to dip into oh I try to keep it
as low as possible because I'd want to
make sure I haven't you know as much of
that Nest day going into that home
purchase yeah what's your household
income
um yearly we're about 90 000. okay
because what I'm wondering is if you did
dip in let's say for the 30 that takes
that account down to 220 then how much
would you need to put down for the house
and would it get you there within your
timeline
yeah we the houses are about 450 here
when where we want to buy and like for
about the level of house that we need
um so it's like we can afford it even
without such a big down payment but we
want to be have it paid off as soon as
possible making making 90 and having a
you know 200 000 home loan on a 15 year
that's going to add up as part of your
take-home base so my goal would be for
you guys to do a 15-year fixed where the
payments no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay and that will help dictate
how much down payment you mean you need
and if it means we got to wait another
six months because we got a minivan then
it takes another six months but I
wouldn't shortcut that process that's
Point George making sure you're doing
the math on both sides of it making not
just planning for the car but also
making sure that you're able to get the
mortgage that you want the the best
possible way now when it comes to a
minivan it's so dependent on the brand
and where you're getting this car from
and the you know the condition of it and
so do you have a specific one in mind
yeah we do
um because the same one that we had just
the newer you know we just need a newer
version and preferably one without a
salvage title this time we ran any
problems
um
basically it's a Chrysler Pacifica oh
yeah I've had some of those as a rental
car those things are sweet
yeah I'm not gonna lie if you say so Joe
everyone that hates on minivans next
time you're you're getting a rental and
you step into one of those things it's
luxury so sweet right with little kids
it's our only option it's the only thing
we even want yeah so I I would say get
the get the van that you want knowing
that it might set back your Home Savings
goals by a little bit
who that's tough and so that might mean
we go for a 20 000 because man it's
gonna losing the extra ten to go for the
30. and minivans are just expensive the
car Market's still crazy so you go for
the ten thousand you might have some
repairs closer down the road that is
true I feel like I'd go the opposite
route you go as cheap as possible well
not as cheap as possible and mind you
this is not right or wrong what I'm
saying I I would go I would start with
the house and I would say okay if I do
my calculations how much money must I
have to get this house and then with
whatever's left that would kind of Be My
Band budget because I wouldn't really
want to sacrifice waiting on the house
for the van yeah
how do I create extra income to where
this doesn't hold up facts though that I
love that so that's a cool goal to have
too and that's something we did was go
all right I'm gonna get the 30 000 van
but I'm gonna make up the difference
with side hustles and I'm willing to
work it out so either way there's
sacrifice and so it's just depending
where you're going to do that how you're
going to do that when you're going to do
that you guys have done an incredible
job I'm so proud of you what I love
about these conversations is we're
talking about options which is a great a
great thing when you're handling your
money right you're walking through these
steps you're doing the right thing then
we're talking about what's better this
or that there's not really a a
quote-unquote wrong answer here it's
just like what how do we want to get
there faster is it this or that and I
love those conversations it just proves
that you're doing things the right way
so very cool I love options plural most
people have gone to the show when
they're in a bind it's just option and
they think well this is the only option
I gotta go take out the HELOC and we go
no no no how did you back yourself into
this corner you've got options but when
you're debt free and you got a pile of
money in the bank it changes it's fun to
have the conversation of your life love
it thanks for the call all right let's
go to Mila in Portland Oregon Mila
welcome to the show
hi thank you for you for the call sure
what's going on I have a question about
a budget we finally talked my husband
into sitting down last night and going
over a budget with me together because
I've been talking to him for about a
year and he's like yeah yeah do whatever
you want and I'm like no I want to do
this together so she sat down yesterday
and um some of his responses I was kind
of shocking he wants to put away a
thousand dollars from each check we get
like we get paid twice okay each of us
so that's four thousand dollars a month
he wants to put away and to me I don't
know I'm just going to find out is that
reasonable well there's so many more
questions how much are you guys bringing
home and what's the goal of saving this
money
so he kind of got lit up because he
wants to buy property he wants to buy a
house or land to build on and he um
we're bringing home anyway for from
eight to ten ten thousand cash or like
is that your take-home pay take home
yeah okay so it leaves you with what
four to six
yeah to I calculated we spent about
three thousand dollars in like Bare
Bones okay and so that's almost half of
our income he wants to save into a money
market account or high yield savings
account sorry do you guys have any debt
no no doubt we actually are no we're
really frugal people who don't spend a
lot of money are ready and so for him to
say that I was like we don't and you
have an emergency fund
uh yes we we do have
money in the bank we have about I don't
know fifty thousand dollars maybe that's
great awesome and so that's way more
than six yeah you said your bare bones
are three months so even six months of
expenses is 18K yeah so let's call it
20.
right okay 20 000 for your emergency
fund you have 30 000 liquid cash you can
do what you want and you're saying he
wants to save an extra 48 000 a year to
buy a house
yep forty thousand dollars a year is
this a house for you or is this a house
for like I'm investing in real estate
no if you want to um we have a smaller
property a very small home and so he
wants to have more land around the house
so maybe buying a house with a little
more land on it so do you get your
homeowners right now do you have a
mortgage yes yes it's a very low
mortgage what's left on
eighty thousand dollars eighty okay how
about this for a cool goal let's pay off
the mortgage First You're Building the
equity it's a four savings plan and as
soon as we have that paid off we can
start stacking up that cash but I think
it's a wise goal as long as you're
investing fifteen percent to retirement
the rest the world's your oyster but
beyond the same plan if you want to do
three and here's why have a why when you
come to the conversation yeah I like
that versus I know I think it's a great
muscle to build that savings muscle it
will serve you well as a couple thanks
for the call Mila that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books my thanks
to Jade warshaw all the folks in the
booth and new America thanks for
listening we'll be back soon
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by my fellow
Ramsey personality Jade warshaw we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money and I know we got a lot of new
listeners coming into the show we're so
glad you're here and if you're wondering
you want to dive deeper into all this
lingo we're throwing out there baby
steps three B five six you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and we will help you
figure out the next best step for you in
your financial Journey based on where
you're at today that's
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button alright Jack is kicking
us off this hour in Austin Texas Jack
welcome to the show
hey how you doing folks doing great how
are you
I'm good thanks for asking
um so yeah I'm in credit card debt and
um I'll just give you the numbers to
start off with uh we could say 26 000
and combine credit card debt across five
uh credit cards
uh in addition to that I also owe 12 000
on my car that I'm still paying uh so 38
000 it looks like we're in total
um I can tell you my multi expenses
right now if you're interested What's
the total expenses per month
total expenses per month is fourteen
hundred dollars approximate all right
what's your take-home pay
take home pay I can do about 2500 per
month for a total of 30k per year
okay that's your take them so you're
making about what 45k
uh I'm sorry again can you repeat that
are you making about 45 000 gross
yeah no no no no no no no I think micros
is the 30k right now I'm doing delivery
with doordash and ubereats okay so
everything I'm getting is just I'm
cashing out oh you're having to pay
taxes on that down the road
yeah okay all right I got it and what's
your question today
well what I want to know is mostly just
trying to focus on the credit card debt
um
three of those credit lines have already
been charged off two of them are still
active but with the impending Loom that
they're going to be charged off
the highest one is around 9000 the lower
one is around 2200.
what I want to know
um because I have about 8 900 Mi watt
401K wish Rob
is if I should pull that
to curb this debt
specifically for these active accounts
so that they don't become charged off
because I want to avoid as many charged
off accounts as I can possible and then
even further than that you know
bankruptcy
uh because if it's just a matter of if I
have to pay taxes now Visa X tax season
and it's like okay I'm paying money
perhaps I'd rather do that than have
this video for the next seven years
that's my mindset so you know without
you're breaking up Austin a little bit
Jack make sure to speak directly on your
phone okay so we hear you I don't think
bankruptcy is in your near future me
either this is not that kind of
situation very rarely what I'd say that
might be the best option for you it's
not even on the table I agree you're far
from it
okay and and the reason I say that is
because they're so far for you to go on
your income that it's not like you're
you know at the top of your income and
you've got this crazy dead and your back
is against a wall you're you have
actually a wide open field in front of
you you've just got to start running
right you know how old are you
28. all right so you're doing a lot of
door dashing and things like that what's
the what's the long-term plan
career-wise
uh not to be doing this
um I was let go of my last job
um in June of 2022 uh so that's the
reason why I'm doing this but for long
term I can't say exactly what I do want
to do um but I do expect to be making
minimum within the range of like 35 to
maybe 50k just with my experience so far
but it definitely what kind of work is
this what were you doing uh
prior I was doing
um
just like an advisor for a video game
company with their accounts and then
whichever way I could drive them from
there so I did get some testing
experience so if I could go into testing
for companies that's the experience I
also have as well can I ask a question
so you said you got let go June of 2022
I'm gonna kick your butt a little bit
what's taking so long
to to bounce back here
um it's part of the problem that I've
got myself into this predicament for the
last four years anyways I'm just now at
the point where
I want to put it back to it
um I've acknowledged that I've had it
but it's just pure laziness that's all
it is are you living alone
well uh I'm renting a room from somebody
but yeah I only account for myself no
other defendants no spouse no so no I
can catch myself okay
well there's only one way out of this
and it's you getting your button gear
and making more money and selling stuff
and maybe even the car I mean that would
clear some debt what's the car worth
um if I'm just going off of the Carfax
email I get monthly I think it's around
18K it's worth it
yeah so you net six and you can go buy a
car for six and it clears your car
payment which is how much
uh four or eight a month for 12K
remaining could you pay off some credit
cards if you had an extra four or 500
bucks a month
that was rhetorical the answer is yes
yes yeah yeah sure I'm selling that car
today and then I'm attacking whatever
profit I can make after I buy a beater
car I'm gonna use to attack that
smallest credit card debt Jack I'm gonna
I'm gonna use the words of Dave Ramsey
here you can wander into debt but you
can't wander out of it and you've been
you've been wandering in the wilderness
here for several several months and you
got to get your butt in gear dude you
got to start running out of this and you
can your income man you you've got
nowhere to go but up there's a really
beautiful place about being at the
bottom the only way to go is up and
you're right there the the world is your
oyster you can go out there and make
money don't sit around and wait for your
dream job get a job that makes anything
more than what you're making now and
take it tell yourself hey this is just
temporary it's means to an end but by
all means keep going forward keep making
sure that every step you take is getting
you a little bit closer to where it is
that you want to be but do not stay
right here do not stay at at 2500 per
month don't do it keep pushing and keep
pushing until you you it's 38 000 it's a
lot of debt but it's not that much debt
right and we're about to clear 12 of it
let me we're gonna clear it that car is
gone dude
what kind of car is it
2018 Camry SC we're gonna get you a 28
Camry SE down the line when we're not
broke it'll come back there you go but
right now let's clear this up let's go
get a retail job that pays 18 bucks an
hour boom you just gotta raise and then
on top of that let's go wait tables at
night you're a single guy this is the
time of your life to do those kind of
sacrifices what were you making in back
in June before you got before you got
let go
uh 15.75 per hour I think uh I was
making
just high of 2K per month bringing home
that's after college that's working for
the video game company
that's correct I think we got to set our
sights higher oh yeah let's shoot you
can work in video games but we're not
doing it for what we could make working
at our local hardware store all right
yeah
so have set a real big goal of where you
want to be five years from now but in
the next year let's get rid of this debt
let's get the IRS offer back pay your
taxes make quarterly estimated payments
and call us back when you're debt free
man this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by Jade warshaw
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five well a
lot of you have questions about taxes
and it's that time of year we get it
taxes are confusing nobody wants to talk
about it but we're willing to be brave
and do that and so I want to unpack a
question from one of our listeners
here's what they ask I'm really nervous
about trying to do our taxes ourselves
but it's almost 300 bucks to get them
done with a tax Pro what should I do
this is a common conundrum people have
so here's how we look at it if you think
your tax situation is pretty simple you
can definitely try using tax software
we've got one called Ramsay smart tax
that will guide you through the online
filing process step by step anyone can
do it it's super simple we walk you
through it and you don't pay until you
file so you actually have a chance to
figure out if it's right for you if you
just want to go check it out plus the
federal classic version of Ramsay smart
tax comes with built-in support there's
also a premium version that gives you
priority level support for all of your
questions and if you still feel
uncomfortable filing taxes on your own
it's worth it it's worth the money you
can connect with a tax Pro that makes it
all really easy and if your your
situation is complicated yeah you've got
properties and all kinds of jobs and
side hustles and you're self-employed
you better be working with the tax Pro
you know what I'm doing George I'm a get
a sinking fund
you know it makes me feel
it just gives me a headache it's the
same reason I I pay someone to mow my
lawn could I do it myself yes that's
debatable but you know what I'm buying
my time Insanity back is what I'm doing
now some people a friend Ken Coleman he
loves to get out there in his new
balances and just go to town on that
long did he take his shirt off God bless
his neighbors
guys sorry
extra from Twilight when he's got his
shirt off all right
well I don't know how we come back from
that but here's the deal we've got a hub
for all of you with resources links to
everything I mentioned at
ramseysolutions.com tax if you want to
learn more about Ramsay smart tax or get
connected with the Ramsay trusted tax
Pro like one of our endorsed local
providers again ramseysolutions.com
tax Jade's still losing it over here
you just painted such a clear the
Twilight is what it was the Twilight for
me Vivid
all right let's go to the phones
Christian joins us in Los Angeles
California Christian welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me sure how can
we help
so
um I'm 20 years old and when I graduated
high school uh my dad said that he was
going to buy me a car based off an
arrangement that we had but he ended up
leasing a car for me a three-year lease
uh the lease ends in May and uh he
agreed to pay half of the remaining
balance which is 15 000. that's just I
was wondering if it if it's still made
sense for me to uh pay 7 500 to have a
relatively new car even with the
craziness of life and becoming an adult
coming up and how expensive that is
how old are you
20. okay and you have the money to do
this
yeah I do oh that's good and so it's 15
grand for the buyout at the end of the
least dad's gonna pay 7 500 you pay 7
500.
correct I think it's a no-brainer and
here's why we hate leases with an
undying burning passion but the dumbest
part of those decisions is over you've
already paid for the depreciation or dad
did and so now you getting 7 500 bucks
and trying to buy a car you're gonna
have a hard time doing that versus
getting the car that you already have
yeah that makes sense I was just
wondering because I'm pretty sure I
could get him to give me the 7500
instead of it just disappearing if I
decided not to buy it out and so the car
is worth probably around like 21
000 and so well here's what either way
why not buy the car he puts in 7 500 you
now own the car free and clear you can
go sell that car for 21 000.
okay
and that puts 21 000 in your pocket to
buy whatever car you want
yeah it's just a hard pill to swallow
um especially being so young and knowing
that like I'm trying I graduate college
in December and I want to get married
next year and all this other stuff and
that's just a large chunk of money to
have gone
what's your so what's your other option
then what do you want to do
I don't know buy a beater car for like
five thousand dollars you can do that
but I would I would still because of
this transaction what the car is worth
pay for the car you put in 7 500 dad
puts in 7 500 that's 15 you sell it for
21.
you now have 21 000 you take 6 000 of
that leaving you with 15 left in savings
oh okay do you see the math well do you
see what he's doing there for you so
you're still better off going through
this trend I know it's a lot of Hoops to
jump through but you're gonna end up you
know netting six grand more than if you
just took the 7 500 from Dad so you're
spending some money up front to make
some money down the line
got it
okay I'm with you I I just wish every 21
year old was forced to to have a beater
car I know right I just don't I know I'm
old school I don't think young kids
should be driving nice cars and it's not
just because I was jealous driving my
beater Honda Civic while these 16 year
olds are driving brand new Jeep
Wranglers I'm like
you're gonna wreck that thing and then
you're gonna get a new car and it
creates entitlement to where that's now
the worst car you ever drive in your
life that's true I think you should
always I'm a kid it depends on the kid I
know you know you you should always
upgrade George you're right about that
like nobody needs Christian you know
what you need to do man
yeah proud of you for not feeling like
you deserve a 21 000 car that's what I'm
talking about but I like it all right we
did what we needed to do there Nick
joins us up next in DC Nick welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely what's going on
uh yeah so my question is basically I
feel stuck between either baby step 3B
or if I'm on baby step seven oh I like
that question why is that
so I'm 26 I live in DC
um you know I'm debt free at my
emergency fund I'm single no kids all
that good stuff
um and you know I'm working my job and
I'm able to save about half my income
which is pretty good
um but I'm also renting with a couple
housemates and I just feel kind of stuck
because I can't afford to buy a house
out here even with like a 20 down
payment and all that kind of stuff so
I I don't really know kind of where to
go from here where do you want to go
what's the goal
you want to be a homeowner in DC it's
been a while
um I do want to be a homeowner
eventually but
probably not for the next few years
probably like I see that as maybe
something like
four or five years away
um which is also kind of complicating
how I should save for down payment for a
house eventually because
typically from what I want from what
I've heard from listening to your guys's
shows like you usually don't recommend
investing in you know mutual funds and
things like that if it's shorter than a
five
mm-hmm
losing the money so I don't know if I
should just keep piling up money in the
bank and get like the you know measly
two percent on it or
or what I would because here's the thing
you said the time is going to pass
regardless right those three to four
four to five years are going to pass
regardless and you know no you're not
going to have enough money in a year and
maybe not even two years but if you're
piling up that money there is going to
come a time where suddenly you have
enough money and some of these high
yield savings account are getting more
than three percent some of them I've
seen over four right now yeah some of
them are pretty decent
um and when it comes to that that rule
of not investing the money unless it's
over you know past a five-year term
there's actually been some study done on
that of what How likely you are to make
money off of that yeah return after five
years and it drops decidedly after three
you know from three years even to five
years so that's why we say that
um because there's still even a risk if
you were to leave it for five years it's
just considerably
um less so it's up to you I mean only
you know your long-term goals if you're
like hey man I'm renting I'm enjoying
this I'm happy to just keep plugging
money putting it aside for babies step
3B if you were to jump to baby step
seven what would that look like for you
is that you saying I would rather do
something like real estate like what are
you
um as an investment like what does that
mean for you
if I were to jump to baby step seven I'd
still be ranking
um but I'd probably just
I don't know I just like kind of go on
more vacations I guess
um that's the kind of part of the
quandary of where I'm at I think we find
some balance for now Nick I want you to
live your life and not just you know
devote your life to a down payment live
your life but also have an aggressive
down payment savings goal and maybe it's
a condo maybe you move from DC to make
this more affordable but don't wait 10
years and don't jump anything a year
from now let's set a reasonable goal and
work towards that this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour opened phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
time for our question of the day which
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need to make
repairs schedule routine maintenance or
find local help for Home Improvement
projects neighborly is your source for
Reliable home service providers in your
area just go to neighborly.com and start
your search all right today's question
comes from camber in the baby steps
Facebook group she says when you have a
company match does that count towards
your 15 my husband's work has a three
percent match we invest three percent of
his gross into our RSP which is a
Canadian equivalent to a 401k and the
employer contributes three percent would
you say that this is three percent or
would you combine it to make it a six
percent contribution towards our 15
that's it's a really good question and
we hear this a lot George because a lot
of companies do offer a match which is a
great thing however we really just kind
of see that as you know icing on the
cake per se we actually don't count that
towards the 15 it's really gravy for the
Canadians so they're putting it on
poutine yes protein for the fries
they're gravy on the fries I just want
to make sure the Canadians get it I love
it thanks George appreciate that that's
such a good always thinking about you so
baby step four in our Ramsey Baby Steps
invest 15 of your household income yes
into retirement which means your money
not your employer's money off the gross
off the gross and so there's there's
good reasons for this number one we
don't know what your employer is going
to do this year next year but we know
what you're going to do invest 15 of
your income into retirement that will
cause you to be wealthy regardless of if
you have an employer match or not and I
don't know about you but I would want
more in retirement rather than less heck
yeah so if it's 15 with the employer
match but 18 if you did the 15 on your
own I'm doing 15 on my own I know right
and some of these matches it takes time
to vest that's true I don't want you
tied to your job because now you're
beholden to the match and getting this
money because you're counting on it as
part of your 15 yeah that's a really
really good point yeah I just like the
idea of building that muscle of of
contributing 15 regardless and in the
end like we said it's gravy on the
biscuit gravy on the fries and if you
had a six percent match but then you
move jobs and all of a sudden there was
no match now you don't know how you you
can't budget yes you're not used to that
so I like just being used to setting
that savings on autopilot it comes out
of my income before it ever hits my bank
account that's right Ramsay with our
401k and I love that because now I just
learned how to live on less I love it
and I flex that muscle set it and forget
it Ron papil was that the rotisserie
chicken reference that's it of course
she's a real one
all right let's go to the phones Lynn
joins us in San Jose California Lynn
welcome to the show
hi thank you Jade and George for taking
my call absolutely like many listeners I
wish I had started listening to you
years ago me too
I know
anyways here's the situation well the
question is what if anything can I do to
use what money I have to make more
and here's my situation I have no debt
own the house
and 73 retired
but
my car is 16 years old my water heater
is 14 years old my refrigerator is 17
years old I need a new stove my house
needs repairs and a new roof
that's a long list I know but it is a
long list isn't it and I I'm just very
stuck as to what to do
and nurse about my income I only let's
see
make oil income just Social Security and
a little bit of attention 31 000 a year
you said you have no payments including
you don't have a mortgage
no mortgage do you have any money in
savings currently
I have about
000 in savings and that's pretty much
all the money you have to your name
outside of this pension coming in Social
Security coming in
yeah I have on hand cash fifty thousand
and yeah twenty thousand in checking and
that's it and that's on top of the 143.
yes okay great so we have over 200 000
in liquid cash yeah hey good job on
being debt free good job on having that
mortgage paid off you've got three to
six months of savings you've done a good
job it just sounds like your nest egg
your retirement egg isn't what you
wanted it to be you know for you to
easily handle you know some of these
Appliance and just like that upkeep of
of life right yep exactly plan on being
in this home for the foreseeable future
well here's the glitch I live in an area
that is
outrageously priced I cannot afford to
relocate in this area
besides that I have a daughter who lives
on the property
she works full time but she's not a um
in a highway Turner and cannot afford to
live on her own
um so so you would put her in a bind if
you chose to move yes exactly and uh
yeah and this is not a house I want to
stay in because it's uh it's just high
maintenance what could you sell the
house challenging
you know uh because of our area probably
I don't know uh roughly close to 650
000. wow that could set you up for
retirement yeah that would set you up
for retirement
if I moved to Arizona or Tennessee I'm
wondering what's keeping you there other
than your daughter what if daughter
moves moves with you and you guys live
in the same area or what if you let
daughter be daughter how old is she and
spread her wings and fly
well my I just don't know where she'd
live so I feel very is she physically
able
yes okay and like I said she does work
full-time but she's not a highway
Journey what's a highway Journey because
California I I don't know what a high
wage in California is
oh well I don't either but for this area
it's it's uh you know like let's just
say something to rent here goes for
about 2500 a month I'm calling a little
bit of BS on her situation because I
think that she here's the thing if you
said man she's uh she's disabled or
she's facing this challenge or she's got
uh I don't know there could be a long
list of things but it sounds like she's
just uh you're eight you're you're
helping her out you know you're able to
help prop up her lifestyle a little bit
and make things a little bit easier for
her and that's probably very convenient
for her but uh you have a situation too
and you've got a life too and if you
want to sell your home and do something
different for retirement and change your
situation I'm telling you right now you
have the freedom to do that you don't
have to uh prop up your daughter's life
it sounds like she's got a job if she
needs to make more income the same way
you're calling in here trying to find a
way to better your situation she can do
that for her darn self and so just be
better be at peace with that
yeah I understand that you know I'm
guessing she's older
yeah she's uh probably well gosh now
she's probably mid-40s okay and she's
single yeah
yes okay I want to help her with her
career not because I want to punish her
and you know if you move and she's got
to figure it out because I care about
her well-being too and her financial
future yeah because what happens when
she retires broke
yeah that's a problem
yeah and so right now you're a crutch
for her
um not a not a true safety net and so
I'm not saying you have to move I just I
don't know that it's worth doing all
these repairs if you could sell the
place for 650 and move somewhere you
actually want to live and upgrade the
car and live your true retirement dreams
that's what I'm doing
yeah it would have been one thing if
you're like man I love this house I
don't want it but you said it's like
it's too much it's it's all of this so I
I have I'm I'm 73 I'm I'm just I don't
have the hutzpah anymore okay I love the
Yiddish very good well we have two
options either take some of this cash
you have sitting around and start to do
these repairs and upgrade the car or we
just sell the house move we keep the
cash that's in the bank and we set
ourselves up for a better retirement
down the line
sounds like a plan yeah you got it Lynn
wishing you the best yes
oh that's a tough one it is kids parents
Money Retirement it's it's tough It's
it's one of those things you I mean and
I could feel the I could feel her mom
love because you know you love your kids
and you want to do for your kids but
sometimes if you when you do the most
it's actually not so great for them you
know it's a it's a little bit of a
failure to launch there yeah my mom did
that with me and cooking she's an
amazing cook I never lifted a finger
when I came to the kitchen and now here
I'm as an adult I'm you know I'm trying
to learn how to cook for the first time
what are you making bologna sandwiches
no we can't even eat gluten Jay in the
processed Meats get out of here with
that okay okay okay George but it is
tough I need some cooking lessons from
Jade so I'm waiting for you to launch
your your big cooking show one day
series that would be amazing hey more of
your calls coming up triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up America this is the Ramsey
Show I'm George Campbell joined by Jade
warshaw this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money Tyler joins us up
next in Eugene Oregon Tyler welcome to
the show
howdy thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help
um I just recently paid off our mortgage
don't act so sad about it no I'm nervous
on these phone calls oh it's not you're
doing great we're just excited for you
and you guys helped me through it so I
appreciate it because I wouldn't have
got debt free without listening to you
um well it's an honor man you did the
work
but I'm lost I don't know really what to
do I'd like to venture off if I I try
I'm I have my own business and I'd like
to venture off and build that but my
wife wants to keep saving oh what does
she want to keep saving for
well the location we're at is it's a
commercial building with living in the
back
and
she wants to buy a house so we can just
turn it full commercial and run it out
um
my shop brings the front part for the
commercial okay and Mama doesn't want to
live in the back of the nail salon
anymore she's ready no to have her own
space
yeah I think that's fair what do you
think about that Tyler
uh uh I think I have ADD too much I like
to do too many things so I want to
venture off and do you know what does
venture mean it sounds so exotic what
does this mean for you
I'd like to go a CNC machine and start
making
well they're not handmade because the
CNC Mission making it but a lighting
fixtures for my store I'm electrical
contractor so I figured you know and I
you wanted to be a comic book artist
when I grew up so I figured that's some
way to get some creativity into my yeah
boring job so what's this house worth or
this commercial space
current I'm still fixing up about 300
right now okay and what's the household
income
uh last year I met
not 198. okay awesome so 200 Grand and
let's hope that it does that and or even
better in the next year
how quickly could we save up and buy a
house
[Music]
fix the building
two years and what's it cost to fix the
building
if I don't get extravagant there we go
I'm guessing your wife is like does it
really need to be that fancy and you go
overboard and spend way too much money
on time because you just love this stuff
yeah yeah it sounds like okay from what
you said before about you know you guys
are living in the back of this
commercial building it sounds like a lot
of your life has kind of revolved around
your business your business Tyler wants
yes and I I I your wife is not on this
call but I'm hearing something in my
spirit telling me that if you can't do
both I mean doing both might be a good
idea but if you can focus more towards
what she's maybe wanting to do this time
that could be I'm just I'm sensing
something here uh Tyler am I off base or
or tell me if I'm off this no no she's
she'll let me do whatever I want mm-hmm
but I don't wanna I wanna do what's best
for my kids and my wife oh yeah the us
and this house is it attached to the
commercial property
yeah so you can't just sell the house
outright but keep the commercial side
it's it's right on the highway so it's
going to be it's no I not too many
people want to live on the highway yeah
so your your Equity is kind of locked in
there as long as you run this business
from the space
correct okay so we need to save up cash
elsewhere and get it home
um is this something where you would
want to pay cash or would you take on a
small Mortgage and pay it off quickly
with this house that since she started
listening to you and me on cash
okay that's a great goal but if you were
going to say hey it's going to take us
five years to save up and pay cash and
she's got to live in this space for the
next five years I think we need a
different solution either take on a
small mortgage or we go rent somewhere
until we have the money but I love you
living you guys living right now without
any payments
yeah it's not yeah we don't want to go
back to that can you set a small budget
to do these upgrades to the commercial
space
yeah like compromise with her and go all
right I'm not going to go crazy I'm
going to spend I don't know 20 grand
well give me a number
yeah are we talking like yeah I could go
like with 40 because I still gotta I
still got to finish my sign there's
there's quite a larger and what is the
ROI for you doing this
that I don't know because right now my
business an electrical contractor so I
think she wants she also wants to have
it but because it would be nice to have
bring people to come in because a lot of
people like to come in yeah my question
is does it matter to anyone but Tyler if
the lighting is great is this affecting
your income is this affecting the your
business are these needs are these wants
I feel like there's a couple of ways we
need to shift this you know sift this
out George that's my worries you do this
and the ROI isn't there and you don't
make a dime more in your business and it
set us back financially from our other
goals
so that's why I want to put a cap on
this I could put my side stuff away and
just focus on my current business that's
already bringing Revenue in and just
improve that and not Venture off in
anything else I mean with my business
hat on that sounds like the better move
is what's going to create more impact
for the business and for our financial
goals down there you're right you're
right yeah
well whatever you do be on board with
your wife and don't make it hey can I do
this wife and said it's yeah what are we
going to do as a couple what are our
goals and I think once you do that
everyone's going to be happier and we
can find some happy mediums it doesn't
all have to be weighted on one side or
the other that's right and thank her be
like hey you've been on board for all
these things that I wanted to do I
really appreciate that we've got this
money ahead of us we've got some things
that we can do I want to make sure we're
both being represented and we're both
you know
getting to see through some of our goals
here that's right I think that's really
we we speak French around here all right
let's head to Canada home of the poutine
Jared joins us there Jared welcome to
the show
hi guys I really appreciate you guys
taking my call today absolutely how can
we help
okay I'm 39 years old and married with a
daughter and my wife and I are looking
at building a house in the next
two to five years probably timeline this
was wondering what's the best way to be
or what best way to save up for that if
you just like save up like mortgage wise
right or like a little lump sum anyway
for it and do we invest that or do we
just go and get a mortgage right now but
you know we are debt free currently
right now and on our own host and we are
uh I'm a little apprehensive to go back
into that again so you own a house
outright no payments
that's correct would you sell that house
yeah once the time would come like when
we when it would be finished you have to
do it okay what's that house worth
probably around 300 right now great and
what's your savings goal for this new
house on top of the 300 how much are you
wanting to save up
leave up the extra 300 right or like
we're looking at probably spending 600
250 yeah 250 to 350 in that range kind
of thing okay so the total cost of this
new build is about 550 to 600 Grand
yeah yeah it all depends yeah but
probably somewhere in there probably
okay that'll be the low end probably but
yeah
what's your household income
um we're in the it varies year to year
but it's probably in the 110 to 130
range okay
and so you're saying the next two to
five years we want to try to save up to
300 Grand
and do this with cash yeah or if we have
to take on a small mortgage we'll do
that
yeah
well I'm just looking for you guys
opinion on what's what's the best way to
tackle this movie I guess I mean of
course it's great we always are like the
best way to buy a house is if you can
afford to pay cash for a home by all
means pay cash for a home but we also
understand that for some people there's
time constraints on that you know do you
really want to save for seven years
maybe or maybe you want to take a small
mortgage and we're not against you
taking out you know a loan for a
mortgage as long as it's done the right
way now in your case it's slightly
different because you've tasted what it
feels like to be completely Mortgage
Debt free and that that's that's a tough
one you know but I do want to kind of
put you at ease that if you were to take
on a small and I would say small like
you don't want to go back to where you
started you know what I'm saying if you
were to take on just a small percentage
of that and if that was going to shave
two years off of your process that could
very well be worth it for you so the
better parameter to look at is how can
we get a 15-year loan where it's no more
than a quarter of our take-home pay I
think once you're there go ahead and
bite the bullet because them home prices
are a moving Target and My worry is you
save up in five years from now that
house is 150 Grand more than it was
great and so I would go ahead and jump
into it and pay it off aggressively
you're the type of people that will do
that and you'll be in good shape my
friend and I put that money in a high
yield savings account I would not invest
it into the stock market at that short
of a Time Horizon that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George camel joined by Jade
warshaw this hour and the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five you jump in we'll talk about
your life your money and hopefully give
you the right Next Step for your
financial future Natalie kicks off this
hour in Charlotte North Carolina Natalie
welcome to the show
hello thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help
well first of all I'm going to just say
right off the rip that my husband and I
have separate finances
um basically due to on my end there's
some narcissistic Tendencies over there
some emotional abuse we've been together
about six seven years
um so we are separate there we do have
an emergency fund we're on baby steps
four five and six and we have some cash
um at home hidden and some in the bank
obviously and so I found out um after
some kind of bigger fight that he's been
taking from the emergency fund without
my me knowing and
um I thought I could trust him so I've
honestly never thought to count it and
come to find out he's been spending that
as cash and keeping money in his account
for himself so I've never been so close
honestly with that and some of the
emotional abuse
um I've never been so close to
considering separation I've offered
counseling as an option and that is not
an option
um so he said no to council it refuses
he refuses yes doesn't believe in it so
now I'm kind of to the point he's
written me this long letter and talked
to me about it but I'm kind of
in a pinch of can I get someone like
that to ever change or basically
um do I just kind of accept things as
they are he's admitted to everything
after I had to find out he likes to lie
but I find stuff out and then he admits
to it then and agrees that I'm wrong he
hasn't blown up since but I'm kind of in
this spot where I don't know if I should
give up the hope that he's going to
change or
not that it makes it any better or any
worse but how much money are we talking
about
um five grand
and this was sitting in the emergency
fund in the bank
this is at home
to use five thousand dollars in cash
without you knowing
correct and what did he use that money
on
apparently just daily expenses
why did he use the money what do you
think what do you think he what do you
think he used the money on
personal
um
personal uh I guess habits bad habits is
there an addiction
okay some marijuana okay
hey
um
I'm sorry that this is happening this
sucks
it's really hard when you know marriage
is is two folks involved and it's really
really hard when one of the people is
trying and offering counseling and hey
let's work together and the other person
is like I'm out like they've tapped out
and uh
I hate that it sounds but it sounds like
to me like he's tapped out like if you
if you're not willing to do counseling
you're not willing to yeah I mean you
gotta he's got to take a step forward I
mean it sounds like you're taking 10
steps forward and he's kind of taken one
step back going away from you and I hate
that that's happening
um
my in these situations I'm always like
okay let's let's get in counseling or
let's get in let you know let's find a
good church community and get around
some folks who can encourage us and help
us out but it kind of sounds like he's
just said no to all that is he depressed
um and that's the thing and he told me
that he has been struggling with
depression for the past couple years
um and I've tried to talk to him about
that before because his dad brought it
up to me and um he
is not an emotional person so he won't
talk to me about it so yeah and that's
kind of where that and we have uh little
kids together I don't know where
um where to go how many kids you have
three okay is he willing to get medical
help see a psychologist a psychiatrist
what is he willing to do at this point
no church no coupling
basically marijuana's his uh weight
handles that's his advice do you have
Community Natalie are there folks around
you do you have family friends a church
do you have people that you can lean on
and really count on
I do and I have some friends that I can
count on
um some my the thing is people have been
around since the beginning and they are
a little biased at this point yeah
um
so I'm gonna I'm gonna take a page out
of John's book I'm not I have no therapy
background no degree background nothing
like that this is just Jade Jade warshaw
talking and we're talking as buddies
right now you're not in a safe
environment
you've got somebody who's using drugs
regularly you can't trust them they're
gaslighting you and you've got kids
involved and for me that's it I
Sam this is not Sam warshaw but if Sam
if I found myself in this situation with
Sam worsha I'd I'd be hitting the road
I'd be getting out of that situation I'm
not saying that that means you're
getting a divorce right away but I am
getting out of that house and I am
getting my kids to a place that is safe
that there's no drug use involved that
there is no uh my guess is there's
probably some other bad habits at play
here as well and into a physically safe
and mentally safe environment and I'm
glad that you've got some folks around
you is there anybody that you can hang
with for a while while you kind of get
your act together financially and figure
out what that next step is
yes there is I guess the only thing that
scares me is um
I know my my mental health is already at
stake but
my mental health my kids are very little
yeah
so
that's the only thing really
um honestly and you're just afraid
you're just afraid you won't be able to
kind of take care of them on your own
I can do it um it's mostly just being
living with somebody else and trying to
I guess get along that way financially
and then
um honestly it's just the part I came
from separated parents and I made a vow
so that's where I'm struggling and I
don't know I think there's nothing else
you need to get counseling for yourself
even if he's not willing just so that
you understand how to move forward with
this
but letting it just sit and fester or
not do anything about it is about the
worst thing we can do here for you and
the kids and for him
if he needs to hit rock bottom to get
his life together yep
to speed this process up I want this
marriage to work and I still believe
there is hope but we got to get him to a
point where he's angry at the situation
where he goes I got to be there for my
kids yeah and you can't control that
Natalie we hope that that happens but
ultimately you're not in control of that
what you're in control of is you making
a plan what does that look like for you
to to get safe what does that look for
you to get healthy if it's counseling
what do you need to be able to do
financially start tonight get in your
journal and start writing out a
financial plan a mental plan and even a
locational plan for how you can make
this work
um for for your family I hope you guys
do are able to reconcile and you've got
to get people around you you can't do
this alone it's just simply too hard so
if you need to find a church community
in your area do that if you need to find
friends that can come around you do that
but this is this is going to take a lot
of time to just rebuild the trust even
if this is going to work but marriage
isn't 50 50. it's a hundred a hundred
man this guy's giving you zero right now
and that is an unsustainable option
we're praying for you this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right Jade I want to talk about
something that is kind of boring but is
also stressing people out and it starts
with f then it goes D then it goes I
then it goes C oh okay you like that I
think you just gave it away Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation and this
is a word people really you only saw it
at like banks in the little gold placard
remember FDIC but now it's all over the
news yeah that's what they say because
of you know Silicon Valley Bank uh the
bank run the collapse and all of a
sudden FDIC is way more important so I
want to squelch some of the fears out
there that people have around is my
money safe in the bank that's what this
comes down to yes so let's talk about
what the FDIC is and how it works they
insure trillions of dollars uh Bank
deposits at more than five thousand
Banks and Savings in the U.S it's an
independent Federal agency that kind of
functions like insurance for the banks
so the banks are saying we need help
taking on this risk in case something
were to happen and we can't fund it you
guys step in and fund the it's that
simple we have car insurance because we
can't cover the big stuff and the banks
do the same for themselves so they pay
these insurance premiums and that's how
it works so how does the coverage work
then George so if a bank fails the FDIC
swoops in and reimburses customers for
any lost money so if you had 40 Grand
with a bank the bank collapses the
government's like hey we got your back
I'm not losing anything you're not
losing a dime can they take over the
failed bank and they work to transfer
the loans and deposit that to a healthy
Bank to where your money is safe and
they also now have ownership of all the
bank's assets wow okay so they can sell
off what they need they can liquidate
whatever ever they need to in order to
make sure your money's secure exactly so
how much money does the FDIC insure it's
up to 250 000 per depositor per insured
bank for each account ownership category
so that's a lot of word salad to say
this if you're a single person you're
covered up to 250 000 that's that's a
bag if you have a joint account you and
Sam have a joint account you're covered
up to five hundred thousand dollars wow
because it's 250 per person okay so now
can you explain a little bit on if let's
say I'm at let's say I'm at Chase Bank
and I've got a savings account that's
got a large sum of money and let's say
I've got a checking account that's got
some money and let's just say I have a I
don't know a couple of CDs or something
with them yes so this is where the
account categories come into play and so
checking and savings would be one
category okay versus a CD or a trust
those would be different categories okay
and so if you have I don't know why this
this probably relates to no one out
there who's like well that's perfect I
have eight hundred thousand dollars
sitting across my only Dave Ramsey you
could open Accounts at different banks
yeah if you want to be safe so 250 and
One Bank 250 another bank 250 in another
bank so case in point let's just say
sold your house and you've got a nice
little Nest Egg of change let's say you
sold your house you got 300 000 you're
sitting on and you're like um that's
just over the limit you could if you
really wanted to be safe you could say
I'm going to put some of this with Ally
Bank high yield savings account and I'm
going to put some of it you know at one
of the other high-yield savings accounts
yeah and I would rather have it in a
high-yield savings account anyways
Stacks making you know three or four
percent so it doesn't apply to a lot of
people but everyone's kind of freaked
out by this but rest assured the FDIC
has never failed in this way they've
never run out of money they've got you
know over a hundred billion dollars plus
any Bank assets that come their way
right through these collapses that they
can sell off now what this doesn't cover
Jade is Investments so you're starting
right right right your mutual funds your
crypto life insurance annuities and so
you're taking on a risk by investing
into the stock market the bank's not
going to cover you let's use your money
the only way that there might be some
coverage there is you know when you
first put that money over to The
Brokerage before you've invested it and
it's just kind of like sitting on hand
in that money market that would be
protected I would think up to 250 000
yeah but go ahead go on ahead and invest
that money don't just let that money be
that's the bigger thing if you called in
and you're worried about this I'm going
what are you doing sitting on 800 000
tripping either invest it put it towards
real estate yeah use it towards
something
um maybe you just have that across
multiple high-yield savings accounts
worst case that's what I would do if I
had that much sitting in cash yeah which
I don't so don't come at me we won't
come at you here's the bottom line stop
worrying about everyone else but
yourself you are in control of your
finances sleep easy at night this is not
a problem people need to worry about no
they're scared of like what if everyone
did a bank run at once in the United
States and we didn't have enough we got
bigger problems at that point America
yeah and we've never expected I mean we
experienced it with toilet paper
remember that during the pandemic
everyone freaked out there wasn't going
to be enough toilet paper and all of a
sudden there wasn't enough toilet paper
yes but I never met and I might be going
too far here I never met one person who
was like Jade I wasn't able to take care
of business we found a way listen you
guys did you meet anybody I'm just
saying I'm not trying to use generic
brand okay you go down to one ply you're
in a dark situation I had somebody give
me a bunch of one play roles like as a
Fail-Safe in case we ran out and do you
know what happened 2020 went and went on
in that one play stayed in our garage I
ended up giving it away because I'm not
there's some places I'm not going hey
that brings a whole new meaning to if
crap hits the fan there you go I'll end
it there but hey we've got a great blog
on this topic FDIC not toilet paper go
to ramseysolutions.com we'll also put it
in the show notes all right let's get to
the phones Kelly joins us in
Philadelphia Kelly welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking the time to
speak with me today sure what's your
question
so uh let me preface this with saying
that I was um previously involved in a
financially abusive relationship so I
take Financial Security very seriously
um and makes me nervous
um I am in a somewhat new relationship
um the relationship I'm referencing was
four years ago so we're past that this
new relationship is moving along quickly
um however I just found out that they
have a significant amount of debt
um with not a lot of income and I'm just
not sure if if
something I should you know try to work
with them through or if I'm just sort of
putting myself in a bad situation
considering their Tendencies to make
poor decisions with money was he hiding
it and you found out or you were just
talking about it and he it's just kind
of come up naturally
so it's been pieces it started when we
were talking about the hypothetical
wedding stuff and I said you know given
my history I was leaning more towards
separate accounts the more I learned
about you know this program I learned
that you want to be able to share
accounts but for sake of the
conversation
um I mentioned separate accounts and he
got really offended and I brought up I
was like well you've told me that you're
bad with money before and I didn't know
what that meant then he mentioned a low
credit score and I'm like well we got to
fix that before we get married I mean I
I can't have it in you know affect my
car insurance and all my rates and
everything I've worked too hard to get
where I'm at
um and got to a point
four months wow we're already talking
about marriage
yeah and that's the other thing too is I
I sort of am kind of feeling like maybe
there's a reason why he's trying to move
me like put you know put pressure on it
he knows that financially I'm secure I
mean I don't you know I'm not a
millionaire yet but I think it's why I
think he's using you in a sense of like
well she's financially secure I'm gonna
hitch my car to this wagon yeah is he
trying to freely
I don't think that but I do know and I
he admitted that if I didn't push and
cry about what's your credit what do you
owe that he would have kept it from me
because I'm the only person in his life
he has ever told about his debt okay I
mean it may just come from a place of
Shame and guilt and baggage and so if
we're going to give him the benefit of
the doubt but I agree we need to pump
the brakes on this relationship and
here's the thing we need to figure out
values and goals because people are
willing to change right I mean right I
would never say hey don't date a guy
because he has debt but if you say this
guy says he's fine staying in debt and
he's fine where he's at that's a huge
red flag to me yeah is he willing is is
he actively working to pay off some of
this debt is he is he saying things like
yeah once I get out of debt blah blah or
you know what what are his views moving
forward because just because you know he
started there that doesn't necessarily
mean that's his future so
yeah so
um we had to talk about it once I found
out that it's 70 grand and 50 of it was
required in the past two to three years
um by just credit card nonsense
knowingly spending money he didn't have
and you know he said he's willing to
work through I mean I went through a
budget with him and everything there's
really not there's like not a ton of
money left to spend he's willing to do
it but I you know I was open about my
concerns that it could happen again and
he got very defensive I would listen to
this voice Kelly what I'm going to do is
send you two copies of The Total Money
Makeover read through it with him and if
he has a heart change and he's ready to
go gun hoe and get rid of this stay with
him
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
hey if you like the show which I hope
you do if you're listening right now
please please consider subscribing to
the show wherever you're listening
leaving a review and sharing this with a
friend if you're anything like me it's
hard to keep a lot of shows in your
Rolodex in the Wheelhouse and when a
friend tells me about it I go all right
I'm actually gonna check that out so if
you've been impacted by the principles
on the show the advice on the show we
just want to spread hope and impact this
year and one of the best ways we do that
is through you guys so thank you so much
all right Jade smart conference weekend
is coming up and we're almost out of
tickets so if you've been waiting don't
wait grab your ticket now it's about to
be sold out this is our first event in
the brand new Ramsey Event Center here
in Nashville it's just up the hill from
our headquarters where we're sitting
right now and in addition to giving you
life-changing practical and proven
wisdom to help you be successful in
every area of your life we're going to
celebrate like crazy so April 14th and
15th join myself Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz
Dr John deloney Ken Coleman and Jade
warshaw for an amazing weekend we're
going to talk about how to crush debt
how to find work that you love to do and
improve your overall well-being and we'd
love to meet you and hear your story
maybe even grab a photo and sign
something for you and don't forget
because this is the first event at the
new Ramsey Event Center every ticket
includes a Special Commemorative batch
how fun is that I love that that's
exclusive so General tickets start at
just 119 bucks each but they're almost
gone and remember this is a two-day
event it is my favorite event that we do
the energies just out of control we've
got a live band it's a whole experience
go to ramseysolutions.com events and
grab yours today and join us in
Nashville Tennessee April 14th and 15th
so exciting I got to do a run through on
the real stage in there in the new
building man it's it's it's sleek and
sexy up in there that's all I gotta say
it is a nice building a nice stage to
sound system the team spared no expense
no it's on point you guys all cash let
me remind you okay that's how we roll
all right let's get to the phones
David's up next in Tulsa David welcome
to the show
well thank you for taking my call Jordan
Jane absolutely
question regarding moving from gazelle
intensity to intentionality
so I've always been the type of person
with the personality of like his own
intensity was easy okay you know two
jobs I went to school in fact I'm
finishing up my bachelor's right now in
computer science awesome and as I'm
coming to the end of it I'm also about
to come to the end of baby step three
finishing my emergency fund
I've been trying to figure out like how
do I make the mental switch
of not being so busy not taking on so
much work to being intentional
that's a great question I'm assuming
you're what 22.
uh 32. oh wow you've got a young voice
so I'm curious about this David what
happened in the last 10 years it sounds
like there was a shift for you
um so the last 10 years I I honestly
started my debt free journey in 2017 I
had a major medical crisis
and I put all of my medical bills on a
credit card and then I had a panic
attack because I was like oh no this is
a problem and so I actually hadn't
discovered you guys quite yet I just
knew that I had a big major debt and
that was a problem and so I started just
taking on jobs paying off
um I finally landed a job that was like
40 hours a week and apparently I just
mentally got bored and decided to pick
up a side gig
and then I decided to go back to school
and I'd cash flowed school and all that
wow is that why you were gazelle intense
so you paid off the medical debt yeah
cash flow's cool you've always had a big
goal get rid of that medical yeah
that's interesting what you talk about
is is so
um real I I hear this a lot even in the
FPU class that I was just in people it's
hard for people to shift from that
because when you're in debt you know in
your reason it was it was medical bills
people have that feeling where it's like
crap I have all this debt and they get
scared and that's kind of like that
visceral moment of like I gotta get out
of this and you're running away from
something and you're running so hard
it's creating a you know that adrenaline
it's creating that feeling of excitement
like okay I'm getting out of debt I'm
getting out of debt then you get out of
debt you get your savings done and then
it's like okay what next and that's when
you really kind of have to shift your
why over to it's not just about getting
out of debt anymore it's not just about
like running for your life anymore now
you get to run towards something and you
need to create that same excitement
around that and so a lot of times it
just looks like sitting down and
dreaming a little bit and going man okay
I'm out of three baby step three I'm out
of baby step three B now I get to start
putting away money for me and investing
and really deciding what this next part
of my life looks like in getting truly
excited about that and in working to
create that same even though you're not
moving as quickly you're intentional but
you have that same kind of why
motivation behind it does that make
sense for you
it does so is there any like I don't
know any best good practices as far as
sitting down and finding that next why
like I feel like I've sat down but I'm
well I'll tell you what I do David yeah
I split it into three categories because
there's only three things you can do
with money give save spend and the
problem people find themselves in if
they're big Savers all they do is save
and so they're not open handed with
giving and they're not enjoying life
with spending or they spend all their
money and they have nothing in savings
they're not get or they're super
generous but they are also not they're
unbalanced on the other sides and so
split it up if you have a gold are you
renting right now
No I um own my house awesome and are you
single
yes okay so I would set some goals and
say all right on the spending category
it's time to upgrade the car I want to
go on that vacation I'm going to up the
food budget a little bit now that I'm
out of baby step three I want to eat out
I want to go out with friends a little
upgrade on the spending side saving side
maybe it's hey I want to pay off this
house early so I'm going to set aside a
big chunk of money to do that while I
invest 15 then on the giving side I'm
gonna say all right I'm going to do 10
to my local church I want to have I want
to just spontaneously give someone a
huge tip once a month when I'm out to
eat and that helps me feel balanced
personally to where I'm not over
indexing on one side
nope
so just set a few goals in each category
and you turn investing on autopilot you
turn your extra mortgage payment on
autopilot and the rest you get to enjoy
through doing a budget how does that hit
you David
you know that hits me good I think it's
the dreaming part I have to like you
mentioned I just I have to
I have to hone that in a little bit we
can't do that for you I could sit here
and be like David here's my dream for
you it's got to be David's dream
and so find out what those things are
what those things that light you up some
people like Dave Ramsey just loves to
work the dude's also in Cabo this week
so he also knows how to unplug he loves
to golf and so start to explore what are
those Hobbies maybe you know maybe
there's something you find a whole new
community of friends that you love to do
but that's going to take some exploring
and you have the freedom to do that when
you're not so focused on working 30
extra hours a week to pay off debt yeah
get you a journal and start asking some
questions what makes you what makes you
angry in the world and those are the
types of things that's like I want to
give money to that I want to be generous
in those areas what are the things that
give me energy in life what are the
things I enjoy doing what are some of
the things I wish I was better at and
those might point to some of the hobbies
that you might want to you know get
involved in so just start asking
yourself some questions and get to know
David a little bit better you know you
you were intense and it's you could put
your head down and you just go go
this is a debt free Eat Pray Love
Journey David now to embark on and I'm
excited for you man I am too this is
good I I actually really like that
advice the journal I've never done that
before and never thought of it from that
perspective it's very helpful I like to
just get the thoughts out yeah on paper
yeah it helps me get them out of my
brain yes because there's only so much
room in there it's not a big brain you
know but this is a great a great problem
people have it is when I get out of debt
and they get and they follow our plan
because our plan you've got to be driven
and it's a process but then they go what
now we took a call earlier from someone
who paid off their house their baby step
seven and they're going what do I do now
yeah yeah it's interesting you know baby
step two three it'll get you addicted to
that feeling of like I gotta go fast
like that Ricky Bobby you gotta go fast
all the time and at some point you don't
have to you can slow down you can enjoy
the Finer Things the fruit of your labor
George you can feel like you're doing
something wrong now because you thought
well that was normal yeah but we were
just being weird to get to a place where
we can can be extra weird because like
no one else so later we can live and
give like no one else yeah and people
forget about the second part yes they
just keep living like no one else yes
but they forget to upgrade the car and
go on a vacation and do the thing you
always wanted to do and that thing you
used to do when you were 12 years old go
do that again yes start the start the
side business and start exploring that
and do it without debt and you'll have
no regret it's that simple but I'm proud
of David for taking the right steps to
do that finishing his his bachelor's in
computer science right young man right
there hey more of your calls coming up
hit us up triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is the Ramsay
show
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day Ephesians 2 10 for
we are God's handiwork created in Christ
Jesus to do good works which God
prepared in advance for us to do
Elon Musk said I think it is possible
for ordinary people to choose to be
extraordinary
hey Ephesians and Elon there you go
that's never never a dull Friday around
I've never seen those two that close to
each other and you'll never see them
again this is a first and last on the
Ramsay show well hey does do you get a
little heartburn every time you see the
total when you check out at the grocery
store it's hard to pinch pennies at the
supermarket when your dollar doesn't
stretch as far as it used to and in this
week's edition of the Ramsey newsletter
we've got 30 tips to still get you what
you need at the grocery store without
wrecking your budget and it's totally
free to sign up just go to
ramseysolutions.com newsletter to
subscribe to our Sunday newsletter and
learn how to save money on groceries
it's a tough one Jade that's a I know
you're big on the grocery savings the
meal prep the meal plan but not everyone
is as blessed as you in that Arena
that's true some people really hate
cooking they really hate you know doing
what it takes but I try to make it easy
to where even if you don't like cooking
even if that's not really your thing you
can still Implement these tips save
money on groceries and really learn how
to eat at home in an easy way I respect
it all right go check it out check it
out let's get to the phones Emily joins
us in Dallas Texas up next Emily how you
doing
hi Georgia Jade I am hope thing to get
y'all's a blessing on whether my family
and I should move even though it will
mean an increase in rent okay so um this
past school year I took a job that's
about 15 minutes away from where we
currently live we're in baby step two
with about 17
000 left which feels like the home
stretched to us but this year has been
sort of taxing with two young kids and
driving an hour each way to and from
school and I feel like moving closer
even though it's been increased will
just feel better and um yeah so we
didn't we didn't initially move because
we wanted to make sure it was a good job
fit and we are definitely feeling like
it's somewhere I want to be long term
and so we're hoping that maybe this
summer we can make that move but she's
not sure if it's the smartest decision
with still being in Davis too
so what's your game plan for getting out
of the 17 000 in debt how long would
that take
we're at about six to seven months and
if you move it will extend that by at
least a few months
I mean if increase in rent would be
about 800
degrees so maybe a year but I'm thinking
that I'll be closer to gigs that I can
do contracts hoping that it's a little
motivation
um what's your household income because
um take home this coming year will be
112 to 1 15. okay and then what is the
rent going to be if you move
if we move
hey how old are your kids
they are three in one okay so we're not
talking about pulling kids out of school
Midway through the year that that sort
of thing is not really an issue no not
at all okay that's good
I mean the numbers check out as far as
it not being too much of your take-home
pay you're right at about 25 if you guys
move and you keep your current income
now you are saving a little bit on gas
is that true yes and you're saying yeah
which counts for something working he'll
still be working he's a firefighter in
the town that we currently live in so
he'll be driving every Thursday which
will be less than what I what is what a
lesson I'll I drive now so he's not
driving every day
no how many times just twice a week
he he works every third day so about two
to three times a week I I go to school
five to six times a week and he's okay
and on board with his commute getting
longer
yes it's it's pretty typical in that
field is there anything closer to where
you would be moving that he can transfer
to is there a fire station there
it's a career it's I mean he's at a very
good station okay that he would not want
to move from
her Department I guess when you at first
it sounded like a really great idea
because you were cutting out that that
big commute but then when you kind of
threw in the side that well now my
husband's going to be doing that commute
in the opposite direction it kind of
took the Ringo you know the the Halo off
of it for me
um yeah have you looked into options for
your job is there another place you
could work that's closer to where you're
at right now that could pay the same or
more
no it just doesn't exist in the snow
Texas area it's it's about it would be
an increase of
five thousand to eight thousand
a year I'm not saying this is a bad plan
but I kind of want to put out there that
you also if you guys choose to make this
move but now he's the one doing the
commute you might be on borrowed time
again like he might the same way that
you're feeling the pinch for whatever
reason maybe it's because you're the one
in the car every day I just wonder if
after a while he's gonna start feeling
that and if that's the case fine you'll
figure out what that pivot is but I but
this is a Band-Aid in that at that case
exactly well I don't I don't think it's
a bad move financially
I'm I'm feeling we want to live in that
direction long term and so I think we're
sort of gauging kind of testing the
waters is whether he will be comfortable
with that drive or not also and it's
different because he works 24-hour
shifts versus I'm working eight to ten
hours a day sure yeah true that sort of
the difference well you can always do it
and then six months from now we
reconvene and go this ain't it and you
know just look at your lease terms and
make sure you're not in a pinch on that
but I'd also make sure it doesn't slow
down your debt payoff and so I'd go all
right it was going to be seven months
I'm willing now to pick up those
contract gigs to keep it at seven months
even with the increase in rent I almost
feel like that's that's the must like
that's not really a that would be our
caveat if you do this
yes yes but I get it I'm not a commute
guy I think you're going to get your
sanity back and a lot of time back with
those kiddos
yes I hope so all right well thank you
so much yeah thanks for the call Emily
appreciate it let's finish out with
Andre in New York City Andre welcome to
the show
yes I uh first time caller long time
listener glad you made the leap
thank you how can we help um so yes my
question is I recently traded my
reliable uh Toyota Camry which I owed
about 12 000 on and um I had for about
three years and then I finally ended up
getting so cold my dream car which is a
2020 Jeep Wrangler and um I took out
about 10 000 out of my savings was a
down payment for the car and it's a
three-year loan it's about 1100 a month
but I also just recently got a part-time
job to kind of help pay for the car and
now I don't know if I really need the
part-time job or not because I'm already
working full-time six days a week from
seven to five at my first job and now
the part-time job is from 6 p.m to
midnight goodness gracious
yeah it's it's but it's not it's not
every day but then so the pretty much um
every day back and forth I'm like do I
really need the job do I no I can I can
I'm asking if you really need the cars
yeah then we get rid of the job and the
car
well yeah what's your take-home pay
monthly
so okay so after taxes I'm taking home
about 4 000 a month no no no no no no no
no no dude you got a mortgage payment in
a depreciating asset
is this the dream that you dreamed of
this is a nightmare George
you better be living in that car if it's
1100 a month
in New York City how often are you
driving
um I also have about a 60 mile per day
commute
it no
this ain't it man I'm get how much is
the car worth and what do you all want
it
well with without interest it's 32
000 with with interest it's uh forty two
thousand
well if you sold it today you'd get 32.
is that what you're saying I haven't
really thought but yeah
what's alone
it's a three-year loan 1100 a month
What's the total on the loan that's left
well since I just got the car about two
more I want to say about 31 32 000. so
you sell it today before your sell it
today before you're upside down please
all it takes is one more weird thing
with this car market and all of a sudden
you're upside down on this car and you
have to keep that part-time job right
now you have the option
but yeah right now you need that
part-time job as long as you have a
freaking 1100 car payment
but the other thing I just want to tell
you guys something so I take home the
four thousand a month so a thousand of
that spend 1100 the car
sell the car Andre I don't know I'm
looking at these numbers going Andre's
broke I don't know how you spin it in a
way where you're not and the reason is
because of that car so I'm increasing
income getting rid of the car and then
we can stop the side job get out while
you
while you sleep hey it's George Campbell
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]